if you believe it it will happen if you
don't believe it no one will help you
get there and i've learned this to be
true
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on the
show how are you i'm good michelle
thanks i'm very good
okay in two words what is it like
running a startup uh
in corona times give me the job
uh crazy but you know startup life is
crazy so it's not that
you know different wonderful okay like i
mentioned right before we started if i
were to you know
list all the companies that you've been
involved with in the in acquisition
whether it was
the the you know companies that you
founded was the cto vp engineering or
or anything of that sort i we wouldn't
we wouldn't have been able to fit it in
20 minutes
but i am gonna ask you can you just give
me you know a really brief rundown
where you came from all the way from
when you were in a today in the israeli
defense forces oh
yeah so now oh all the way up until now
when you're running
up nine give me the brief rundown i'm
not sure i can do that because when i
was actually
today that was too long you know my
memory doesn't serve me that
you know that long ago uh but no i'm i'm
the normal kind of
israeli startups startup nation story
what does that mean uh
it's a playbook right that we all we go
we all go
to the military right meaning
the good guys go to kravi you know
and and you know guys like us we go
and build things kind of more uh
programs and stuff
uh so i started there
as a today six years nine with with
school and everything
wow did my own startup uh my first
startup
uh was good it was okay compelled
um what does okay mean just for context
uh i'm sure this kind of startups just
fail so when
you're saying okay that's okay
[Laughter]
it's okay to fail and don't let anyone
tell you different
now so yeah and
you know with start of life it's very
easy to to
um to talk about your successes but
again
you won't be there you're not an
entrepreneur you're not in real startup
life
if 90 of your experiments
fail right i don't know if anyone that
kind of okay
you know you're just in them they can
join
someone and then they will be successful
but that someone for sure
you know made many mistakes and failures
yeah
but in techcrunch you read about the
successes and that's obviously the
cognitive bias that we that we now have
but alone nevertheless you you went
through the you're saying the
traditional israeli route going to the
military
and and doing some meaningful things
there and you know not so much curvy but
other
very meaningful things and then moving
on creating a startup that's okay
and then you're involved in a series of
acquisitions and what i want to get out
of the
these in that you know next 17 minutes
or so is i want to pick your brain about
a few of the subjects that we talked
about
whether it's you know the you know the
guide that the transitions
between you know employer or employee
versus like a founder an entrepreneur
you know what it means to build teams to
build products so let's start with that
first one what does it mean
you know that that dissonance between
you know being an employee versus being
an entrepreneur
yeah i think you you coined it right
there is a dissonance because
for whatever reason uh people look at
startups and founders and entrepreneurs
and think hey that that's
fun we should do that
and then i turn to them and say you need
to you need to have like a bug
yeah you could be somewhat crazy to
actually want
for years you're probably top of your
class
very smart can do a lot of things but
you know let's settle for half the peak
you know work three times as much
for half the pay fail nine times out of
ten
so you really want to do that um
so there is a dissonance between how it
looks like and how it is
i can tell you that entrepreneurs at
least somewhere i look at it they don't
have a choice
okay they cannot take orders they cannot
follow instructions it's very you know
they can try
and they'll probably be good at it for a
while but something inside
will you know will die yeah so i think
that's the main difference
if you can get a job at google
do it i highly recommend doing it
why do you recommend that because i
think this is kind of
um again
i i can't i simply can't
it's uh and if i could maybe i would i
tried meaning
uh blessing my recent company was
acquired by ca and then broadcom
very good position you know good company
different company it's not facebook
right but
i can't it's got i cannot when i had to
choose
what i'm about to do when did you
discover this about yourself that you
simply can't
long time ago when you try and try and
try and you
you rather fail and an attempt of
building something because this is where
you get
the kind of the value you get the value
when you build something right
right uh i'd rather fail there
or be you know successful for doing
someone else's bidding
right so yeah so for me there was no
there was no option other than oh so you
know now i want to extrapolate this and
as you're building your teams across
the different companies i'm wondering
you know
you're you're bringing on to your
startups you know some
oftentimes you know the early employees
a lot of them do have that bug in their
either they're also entrepreneurial they
want to be a part of the success story
but you need you know you need to find
somebody who can take orders and
can fulfill your tasks and your requests
even though they're having this you know
entrepreneurial spirit so how do you how
do you go about doing that
you tell me because i wasn't successful
in doing that
no i'm that serious i have a team of 15
people they do not listen to me
right and no matter what i do
i need to convince them that you know
what i
see is right and maybe they will follow
okay but especially israelis
don't meaning they do not follow other
they talk back
right for example in america this is
something that uh doesn't happen too
often right
yeah so especially with my team that
currently is mostly israeli
uh they don't do what i say
it's very simple yeah well i'm but i'm
sure that
again you know as the ceo and you i mean
at some points
you you do make a decision right and at
some points you say like guys listen
like this is our strategy i mean you
have a few responsibilities hire the
best people
you know make sure you have enough
runway to continue the company and
have a vision for where the company is
headed and you know at some point
there is a difference between your
understanding of the market
and where you're headed versus you know
employee number 15. there must be isn't
there
maybe in number 500 but uh
no and it's you roughly said it the
three three items one is
point to the vision right this is what i
do and you do it
once if you're lucky you do it once if
you're
you can maybe do it twice or three times
the fourth time you know you're out
uh but this will you you point to the
vision
and from that point onward you explain
you pitch the vision and the more
communicative you are
you know people will follow people are
looking for someone to follow at the end
of the day
right you you fundraise
that's the you know that's the
responsibility of the founder if you
cannot fundraise don't bring
you know someone else to do it for you
find a job right right fundraise to
create longevity for the company and
then you hire the best people you can
okay and i added you can because
sometimes you know
this is what you can do but if you if
you hire these people
and you explain to them and they
actually agree with you if they don't
agree with you they will not follow you
right if they agree with you you don't
need to the the the dialogue
doesn't need to happen on a daily basis
right
kind of uh the north star should be
there
yeah so serious so what i'm hearing from
you is a lot of is trust
but it's not just you know i hear a lot
that employees need to trust their ceo
employees need to trust their ceo he
says the vision he or she sets the
vision
but what you're also referencing is that
the ceo has to trust their employees
because in the whole art of
you know talking back and bouncing ideas
and when you're telling me
proudly that your team doesn't listen to
you obviously they listen to you but
when you're saying that
what i hear is a proud statement of my
team
they're entrepreneurial they're
independent thinkers and they challenge
me on my ideas
and that's why we work so well together
because we respect and we trust each
other is that right yeah that's
absolutely correct but again
everything i'm saying by the way this is
not the truth this is not objective this
is
me okay so so you know i've learned i've
tried to be like the
decision maker with i have this right
hand and that right hand
and this right hand and one on my right
hand right
it doesn't scale okay and you know
i was able to go pas i i survived
that era to a point where it's all about
the why
right if i am able to convince you why
we are doing this
you follow me i don't need even to
explain you'll have your own vision and
it's good enough
okay if i constantly need to manage you
yeah
you know we're in a bad place right so
so what what number startup is this that
you're involved with
and something my god come on i don't
remember
is it after is it after two hands so
are you asking how many companies i have
founded over the years
i don't know where you were involved
with no no no that's too many to count
especially in this day and age where i'm
also investing but i'm investing in a
company that i can help
at least at the beginning so i don't
know twenty thirty
four so what i really wanna know is give
me you know your
one or two earned secrets after 20 or 30
companies
that you're watching you know these
scrappy hungry entrepreneurs and these
great teams
and because you're choosing diligently
the companies that you're either
investing in or you're
founding or working for what have you
learned over these years that you know a
young entrepreneur like myself
as i go along my journey i don't have to
go to to 20 30 companies i can just
listen to your advice take it for
and take it as it is yeah you know
listen it in
you know with very um
in a very very limited manner
yeah i've learned something that
i was taught meaning i had great mentals
right it's kind of uh even though that
when i started like
let's talk about the past 10 years
because i don't remember what was before
it was kind of too long ago
right but i had great mentors
right and they taught me i said i know a
lot
but there's far more that i don't know
and i want to learn from people
who actually know so the first thing one
of the things they told me listen it's
all about you
and i said what do you mean about me
it's all about you okay
if you believe it it will happen if you
don't believe it no one will help you
get there and i've learned this to be
true
i've learned that if a founder believes
it's not about being
it's not about believing in god it's not
religion
if you can envision okay the way you're
headed and you actually believe
you can go there a you get there
b people will follow okay so it's all
about the founder
or the founders right co-founders
uh so i i
try to um do it on on
you know where i live again i'm back to
i have some experience behind me
but i'm back to being a founder it's the
same exact experience
you know every other founder has
but also easier what what becomes easier
over time so now that you're
you know a serial founder and you've had
successes behind you and you're coming
up
you're coming now with with up nine
what's easier than before what's easier
than before
first i can tell you that it's never
easy even when you think you know it all
and you've done it all
you learn that because you're not doing
the same thing
right so apparently every story has its
own
unique complexities okay so that's the
one thing but experience does help you
because you know what to expect on the
other hand
other end i i think the the one thing
that kind of
causes people to a halt is the fear
of what will happen and when you know
hey we've been through that crisis and
we've done that and that customer left
us
and this term she blew up right and
whatever you know okay
i know what to expect i know how to
manage it i know how to compare it
to other kind of situations i was in the
past
uh having said that that helps you some
you still need to deal with the
day-to-day with new china and that's the
fun of it
right so it's not like a problem
definitely and now you're investing
and you know we we know each other
through j ventures
and for example and and you're investing
and at the same time you're
you're a the ceo of an early stage
startup right
yeah yeah and to be honest how does that
work
it sounds so you know weird that you're
both investing in in early stage service
but you have an early stage startup of
your own
yeah uh the one thing you learn very
quickly is
uh when you compare your time versus
money
invest the money it's easier you put it
there
it hopefully you chose well right
and and usually i don't just invest
right
it's kind it needs to be the founding
team it needs to be the
industry that i understand so it's more
of a
it's not a guess right right of course
but it's easier to invest than for
example to be an advisor
interesting okay um
and uh to be honest with you i had far
more
time when i was you know in the past
three to four years when i was an
executive in
a bigger company today there's no time
zero time it's negative time so
but again i'm enjoying every second i i
do support
the companies i have invested in or i'm
actively advising to uh but
i'm not taking at least not uh no more
advisory rules
interesting where do you get more energy
from the
you know the the investor in you or the
entrepreneur in you that's an easy
question
that's an easy question i took a
decision a conscious decision
should i go into investments and help
companies
or do the not so logical thing
which is jump back in to where i just
was
okay and uh that takes that takes a
crazy person
to go through all these journeys and
then jump back in and do it again from
the start
yeah but i've realized that a long time
ago
so you have to have this something in
your head and then you cannot avoid it
unfortunately
no no definitely okay alone give me your
two cents about building products that's
also something we mentioned before
you know you've built quite a few
products give me the do's and don'ts
well what when you approach a product
that you're examining
what are you looking for and what are
some of you know the big you know
pitfalls that that we can watch out for
yeah so so assuming you chose the market
right right assuming you chose the
problem set of problems
solution that is kind of big enough to
matter
okay when you kind of there is
you know let's say you have a vision
product a vision market fit
the next thing is product market fit
okay
it doesn't come first but it definitely
comes second and i think this is
critical
and i think you cannot um
over invest in this it's a period of
time
and everything is relatively easy vision
is easy fundraising is easy scaling is
easy
product market fit if you do it right
yes everything else is easy if you do it
wrong everything else become impossible
and i think that's a little
counterintuitive for for i think a lot
of people because
you know when you look at you know all
the you know
fancy youtube videos or all the lectures
that you can attend most of them are
how to raise money and how to build a
strong team and how to how to but i
almost never see you know a session on
how to find product market fit and how
to measure your nps score
how to know objectively whether you've
actually reached product market fit
uh yeah and you mentioned nps and other
tools but i i think that
you know we are all engineers this is
good
and also the bad because we have so many
ideas one of the rules
i had is you have an idea i have an idea
let's forget about these ideas i'm you
would say
killing innovation but that's not
correct right
if a customer tells you that
if the first customer the second the
third this is it this is what we are
going to do
forget about your idea and now having
said that
customers don't always tell you
um they tell you what they want not what
they
need so it's your job to hear them
and then you know reflect back what you
think they need
which will be the base for product
market fit yeah
so that's there's the funny quote from
the night you know
looking back that if we had listened to
cut to what customers wanted
and you know back in the early in the
early 1900s
we just make faster horses
i agreed good example definitely
alone what are you really passionate
about fine yeah startups
entrepreneurship
all these journeys you're i got it
you're crazy but what are you
really you know with it like why do when
you wake up every day
what is like the highlight of your
moment the highlight of your day
listen i have a ton of things i'm
passionate about
okay and uh that you know
there are periods in life like you know
electric guitar and stuff like that
anything related to music
cars motorcycles mountain bike road bike
anything extreme wise diving
you know i had i don't know uh master uh
not master but three stars in diving i
forget uh you know the degree there
when you build a company there's no
other thing
24 hours a day for as many years
right at least that's the way i'm doing
it it's very tough to keep
uh life work balance i have three kids
right here at home in palo alto and
everything
um and i think that we are able to keep
a work-life balance
but you wake up in the morning is slack
and emails and you know stuff like that
so and i'm not sure you know some people
i'm sure many people will tell you
otherwise but this is me
okay and that was before and
this is a period in time it's a few
years that you don't
this is it this is what you do and
you're passionate this is what i want to
do i don't want to do anything
i love it i love it i love it alone
before we leave the most important
question i need
three words that you would use to
describe yourself or that any of your
employees or
or current or past co-founders will
define you as
so um
okay so i would define myself
as a founder and an engineer
okay and i'm trying to keep professional
into the career
not think you know i love my family and
you know we're very much kind of an
israeli family and everything
yeah uh but i think an engineering
entrepreneur
i don't have a third i know you asked
for three but i know how i was
[Music]
how people talked about me and not only
employees but customers crazy ceo
okay and just to explain it's not like
everyone wants to be crazy because it's
maybe fun another thing but
always exaggerate like you go into a
show you're doing something
you're expected to do this do that
okay to a point where actually uh
a prospect not that they came in and say
hey your ceo is crazy
i said god good i feel comfortable
i love it thank you very very much
such a pleasure i learned so much and
and best of luck with the
covid and best of luck with up nine
thank you so much mikhail and uh awesome
initiative i'm so
i'm so happy that you reached out so
thank you thank you